achats croissants ministre breteuil le
plus illustre c'est lui louis auguste
baron de breteuil ministre de louis saez
diplomate en europe
il est nommé à la maison du roy durant
cinq ans il sera principal ministre en
remplacement de necker du 12 au 14
juillet 1789 le plus beau souvenir qu'on
puisse avoir de lui ce fait la table de
tai shen également appelé la table de
breteuil confectionné par neubert est
offert en 1779 au baron de bois taillé à
l'époque où il était ambassadeur de
france en autriche
louis saez lui avait demandé d'être
médiateur de paix et donc de rétablir la
paix grâce à un traité dans la guerre de
succession de bavière ce que le bar en
bretagne a réussi brillamment à faire
sans qu'aucune goutte de sang ne soit
versée
chez les bretons ils sont trois à avoir
eu un rang de ministre le premier de la
famille c'est louis debré auteuil
contrôleur général des finances du roi
louis xiv
charles a n'a que 8 ans en 1789
parce qu'il était mineur son château et
mis sous séquestre par les
révolutionnaires il lui sera rendu
intacte à sa majorité
ce jeune charles de breteuil nous le
retrouvons ici en 1821 dans la
bibliothèque
il est dans son habit bleu de préfet et
il sera nommé père de france par louis
xviii en 1823 un roi alors impotents qui
se déplaçait en fauteuil roulant charles
de bretagne est un proche collaborateur
du souverain français
il est alors l'un des principaux
conseillers en termes de politique
étrangère un goût pour la politique
étrangère que l'on retrouve chez son
petit fils henry de breteuil le 12 mars
1880 le 8e art qui reçoit le prince de
galles futur edouard vii et arrière
grand père d'elizabeth 2 il reçoit aussi
léon gambetta président de la chambre
des députés
cette rencontre qui a lieu chez d'henri
breteuil à la demande du prince de
galles a pour but de jeter les bases de
l'entente cordiale pour cette amitié
franco britannique qu'il était grand
temps de réaliser cette amitié ne sera
signé que 23 ans plus tard en 1904 je
vais maintenant vous présenter la grande
dame de la famille
gabriel est muni de bouteilles plus
connu sous son nom de femme mariée
madame du châtelet femmes illustres de
la famille breteuil gabriel emilie est
une mathématicienne du xviiie siècle
longtemps restée connue comme la
compagne de voltaire enfants elle avait
fait promettre à son père de ne pas
l'envoyer au couvent et de recevoir le
même enseignement que ses frères le
grand ouvrage de sa vie a été la
traduction des principes de newton par
newton avait écrit ces principes dans un
latin scientifique extrêmement complexe
que même ses contemporains scientifiques
ne comprenait pas et madame du châtelet
à tous traduits et surtout elle a
commenté et expliqué les principes de
newton
cette traduction française est toujours
la seule à ce jour les visites du
château retrace cette histoire à travers
100 portraits de famille et une
vingtaine de portraits royaux